「おおきなかぶ」
あるところに・・・おじいさんが住んでいました・・・。
おじいさんはよくやまへ・・・。
野菜を取りに出かけていました。
おじいさんは今日も山の中で
いい野菜はないか、いい野菜はないか
と、探していました・・・。
子：「お゛ーーーい！！！！」
母「おじいちゃんのまねしてるよ」
演技じゃねーぞ！
おじいさんが山を抜けて
海のほうを見ると・・・。
そこには・・・！？
とんでもない光景が！？
ピーーーーー
ヒャーーーー
ピーーーーーーー
ひょろーーー
なんと
今までに見たこともないような
大きな株があったのです
おじいさんは腰痛という設定を忘れて
ダッシュで株に駆け寄りました
ヒューーーーーー
ヒゲが取れましたあー
株やないか！
これ売ったらカネになるべ！
そう思ったおじいさんは
すぐに株を抜こうとしましたが・・・。
大きくて一人の力では抜くことができませんでした・・・。
そこでおじいさんは
この海の近くで
手伝ってくれる人を探しました
「だれか―――――――――！！！！！！！！！！！」
すると
一人の村人が手伝いに来てくれました
彼の走った風圧で
おじいさんのひげは永遠に取れてしまいました
「せーーーの」
「うんとこしょ。どっこいしょ。」
おじいさん・村人A：「まだまだ株は抜けません」
さらに
手伝ってくれる人を探していると
村人がもう一人
手伝いに来てくれました
｢株が抜けんのじゃ」
「せーの」
「うんとこしょ。どっこいしょ。」
はじめ･村人A･村人B：「まだまだ株は抜けません」
「これほんと大丈夫か?ｗ」
三人はさらに手伝ってくれる人を探しました
「すいません…///」
すこしはずかしいおじいさんでした
おじいさんはガチで株を抜きたいと思い
色んな人に声をかけましたが
みんなにガン無視でした≪キッパリ≫
「株抜いてくれませんか～」
まだあきらめるのは早い
大きな株を抜こうとしても基本的に
誰も手伝ってくれません
はじめ・村人A・村人B：「だれかーーーー！」
株を抜こうとして一生懸命色んな人に声をかけました
「株がこのままじゃ・・・。」
「大きな株が抜けません」
～声をかけること10分～
現代の文明に頼ることにしました
おじいさんは自分のトゥイッターを使って
みんなに募集をかけました
「す、すいません・・・。」
「ふっひゃっひゃっひゃっひゃｗｗｗ」
なんと・・・！?
おじいさんがトゥイッターで募集をかけると
四人の男の子がてとぅだいに来てくれました
「ちょっと抜けなくて・・・。」
「ほんとすいません」
「うっ、せーの！」
「うんとこしょ。どっこいしょ」
はじめと村人と4人の男の子：「まだまだ株は抜けません。」
まだ抜けねぇのかよ
と、思っていたとき
一人の☆女の子☆も手伝いに来てくれました
「ちょ、ちょっと株抜いてもらっていいですか？」
「あ、はい」
「うんとこしょ。どっこいしょ。」
みんな：「まだまだ株は抜けません。」
結局そのあと・・・
おじいさんは40分待ったのですが
みんなと写真撮影をして
暗くなってきたのでみんなも帰ってしまい
一人になってしまいました
なぞの声：「カ～～カ～～カ～～カ～～」
おしまい
ンタンタンタンタンタンタンタンタ♪
ターータラララーラータラララータラララーラー♪
タラララーーーーラーーララ♪
タラララーーーーラーーー♪
ンタンタンタンタ♪
ジャジャジャジャン♪
次の動画も見てね！